بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين السلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما بعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
س الانعام
سوره الانعامه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الانعام
صلى الله عليه
ران
صلى الله عليه وسلم سوره الانعام
ustران
ر
ابن عباس
رضي الله عنهما
سوره الانعام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عليه السلام
الله
تسبيح
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الانعام
‏And so
we notice in this chapter and all
chapters for that matter and verses that
were revealed in we notice a particular
style particular way of speaking we
notice a particular tone a particular
climate that the verses have
it is very
different than
م why
was different in was different of people
listen it was us a maority of anon
and the musl there a minority among
[Silence]
‏Islam whether it be with
it be with it be with accusations
whether it be with accusations of
intention
‏easiest way
to tell
when someone does not havely does not
have argument is when they resort to
attacking the intention
of the person that they attempting to
refute and this is what resorted to
‏in his attacks on Musa it wasn't any
refutation of the points of logic or
theidences
and miracles that Musa عليه السلام
provided
that were addressed. Pharaoh did not
address these things.
‏resort to was
attacking
the person
and
ofارون
عليه السلام and accusing their
intentions.
‏ATT
et
مو عليه السلامر
[Silence]
صل الله عل
سوره الفاتحه سوره البقره سوره ال عمران
سوره النساء سوره المائده سوره الانعام
سوره الاعراف
التوبه والاثالر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
موى عليه
‏ar
mi
from
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم السبع الطوال
سوره الانعام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏andes
areer
to and often
byl
as upigion
of the propul
‏are
and found all the prop صلى الله عليه
وسلمves
aroundes
and so much soض
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وصيه
قران
ابن مسعود
من احب ان ينظر الى وصيه محمد التي عليها
خاتمه فليق اقرا قل تعالوا اتلوا ما حرم
ربكم عليكم الا تشركوا به شيئا الى اخر
الايات الثلاثه
if
would
up his final will test that
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قلوا
اتل ما حرم ربكم عليكم الا تشركوا به شيئا
وبالوالدين احسانا
ولا تقتلوا اولادكم من املاق نحن نرزقكم
واياهم
ولا تقربوا الفواحش ما ظهر منها وما بطن
ولا تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تعقلون
ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي هي احسن
حتى يبلغ اشده
واوفوا الكيل والميزان بالقسط
لا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها
واذا قلتم فاعدلوا ولو كان ذا قربه وبعهد
الله اوفوا ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تذكرون
وان هذا صراطي مستقيم فاتبعوه
ولا تتبعوا السبل فتفرق بكم عن سبيله
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تتقون
سوره الانعام
قران سوره الانعام
سبحانه وتعالى
وصيه
قل تعالوا اتل ما حرم ربكم عليكم
هذه الكلمه تعالوا تعالوا
ما زلنا نستعمل هذه الكلمه وهذه العباره
نقول تعال وتعال
تعالوا
لكن هنا بفتح اللام
دليلا على حرف العله المحذوف
يقول تعالوا بمعنى اقبل
لكن في زياده على معنى اقبل
تعالوا يعني اقبلوا
فان انتم اطعتم في هذا
تعاليتم
فتعالوا لا تستعمل الا فيما فيه خير
للمدعو
تقول تعالوا
يعني اقبل على ما يصلحك
ويرفع من شانك
فقوله تعالوا
سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
اتل ما حرم ربك
‏your sent down upon you all
but there more thanite
because the
in a langage
doesn't me toiten't
just me to say conve
الذين اتيناهم الكتاب يتلونه
حق تلاوته
ايش يعني يتلونه حق تلاوته
يعملون باوامره يعملون به حق العمل
ويؤمنون بما فيه حق الايمان هذه التلاوه
soين
‏All of you come forth
let me tell you and impement for you
what your lord has revealed to you so
notice here the miracle
of theران is mention
but also it isou with the miracle of the
propetahi
was not just the book alone
ر الله سبحانه وتالىر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى وكيف تكفرون وانتم تتلى
عليكم ايات الله وفيكم رسوله
نور على نور
صلى الله عليه وسلم معصوم
معصوم
by
the confusion
معصوم
‏everything about him is protect
everything about him with regards to the
spiritual aspect and also with regards
to his mage is protected divinely by
Allah subha
and so
in a
‏was never
toy
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏movement
protect by
in
the propet
conquered before they entered
he had given a command that everyone
who goes to the following homes or
houses is safe except
‏number
was عبد الله
ابي
رضي الله عنه رضي الله عنه now
actually become
he was one of thebes
that wr some thees ofران for the prop
then later from islam
‏poetry
insult prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
and
you know speaking about
prop
and etc so he didn't from is and islam
but went
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عبد الله بن ابي
عبد الله بن ابي صرح
was
عثمان عفان beforeing
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عبد الله
عثمان
pleasم
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and time
are among you that i commanded with what
i
‏And they said we thought we didn't know
what you want from us. We thought it
changed. If you only just looked at us
we would have
followed through with you commanded
earlier. We were waiting to see what you
said.
لا يصلح ان تكون لنبي الله
خائنه الاعين
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الله تعالى next ويك والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
وجزاكم الله خيرا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان
اله الا
الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمد
رسول
الله
حي على
[Silence]
حي على لا
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اله الا
اللهم
انك لا تكذب
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون.
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قول قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل كل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فان الله تعالى
يقول في كتابه الكريم
وقالوا لن نؤمن لك حتى تفجر لنا من الارض
ينبوعا
او تكون لك جنه من نخيل وعنب فتفجر ر
الانهار خلالها تفجيرا
او تسقط السماء كما زعمت علينا كسفا او
تاتي بالله والملائكه قبيلا
او يكون لك بيت من زخرف
او ترقى في السماء ولن نؤمن لرقيك
حتى تنزل علينا كتابا نقراه
قل سبحان ربي هل كنت الا بشر الرسول
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏so mir
some the schar of have attempt to
enumerate
that are through thees of theران
through the narrations of the prop
and is
‏upon that theyceed
not one or two or 10 or 20
more than000 miracles
ranging
from the moon being split in half as
people watched
all the way down to a stone
or his
صلى الله عليه وسلم
رضي الله عنه
take
it would
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
لولا انزل عليه ايات من ربه وقالوا لولا
انزل عليه ايات من ربه
‏would
some
would
all
morey
sa to
everyle person
that cameos him at any given time ‏would
be a witness to some miracle of some
so are saying he hasn't provided us with
any miracles
and this was their argument if a prophet
providence
matter of factنes
in مسند الامام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انا اطب قومي
يعني من الطب ويقصد بذلك السحر
‏magy
tell me and theyer to magicians anders
and theyer to them as
he as
and so said to the prop
said him tell me whats you ‏And I'm sure
that I can find a cure for you. Why?
Because the rumor that was going around
was claiming that the prophet
was they were saying about him all kinds
of terrible things. They were saying,
"Oh, he is he is possessed by a demon.
He is insane. He lost his sanity etc.
These are the kinds of lies that they
spread about him.
‏And so this man came seemingly to do
good and said, "Tell me what ails you.
I'll find a cure for you."
He said, "Would you to see a
miracle?"
The guy said, "Yes, of course." He said,
"That date palm over there and he
gestured to a date palm, a palm tree.
He said, "Call it over here to come and
talk to us."
‏The man looked at this palm tree and
called it over. It's absurd.
‏If somebody told you that, just imagine
somebody tells you that. See that tree
over there? Call it over here. So he's
he just along this yes over there.
قال رضي الله عنه فاقبل
اقبلت النخله تخد الارض خامت
بين يدي رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله صلى الله عليه
‏and
to place now for I want you to
something that all of your years on this
30 40 50 years 100 200 years you have
never a tree moving and walking
‏could not believe in this man
the man
back
people I have never seen
صلى الله عليه
‏that was not enough to overcome this
man's ar
and that is really what it cuts down to
because it is impossible to argue with
something that. ‏How can you refute
that? Impossible.
All of today's technology,
all of humanity's technology
could never even produce not even an
iota of this kind of miracle. And these
miracles were a normal occurrence.
‏people
جاب رضي الله عنه was
himself and they st to make and went
people to themselves they
‏unassum place some could have someevel
privacy and they would themselves and so
he walked with him in order to bring him
his water with him
and so he got to a point where there was
a boulder and there were a coule of
trees that far from each other they were
to far for individually to cover him
‏would
not conceal private parts himself would
conceal his whole body so not seen
himself
the ofity
عليه الصلاه والسلام
and this
جاب
الله
صلى الله عليه ‏is now him hea to be
called so he willing for him
he said i peaked over the boulder and i
saw him take the branch of one of the
trees and walk it over to the other tree
and they were together while he relieved
himself after he finished i looked back
and the trees back where they were this
was a noral occur with the صلى الله عليه
وسلم
whyn't
how make
him
if a propetle
and
‏Allah into
which is rationality at all he gives us
a peak into their psych the pyche of the
arrogant who wishes to re the truth no
matter what cost or no matter
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
why would
come tousion
that's why because he wasn't looking
‏to make
his decion was made based on his whims
his desires because of arrogance because
of jealousy whatever it was the debate
and the argument and the demanding of
miracles this is just to cl what is just
arrance orousy
or
you know
‏they have
not to
disb
they won believe
and here
is givenes ofران
and ines
some the tyes
‏Mir
miracles thatulitude
is from the go.
‏What does that mean? That means that
the attitude of of a human being
receiving a messenger from Allah, his
creator
cannot be the attitude of do what I ask
of you. If you're really a messenger, go
ahad and do this and do that and demand
as if we are in the position to demand
that our messenger perform for us
whatever we want.
الله سبحانه وتالى need
الله سبحانه وى
‏more
are
we are not
to make
as to what the should say how the should
say it or what the messenger should do
or what mir should not be pered
and so
that
لن نؤمن لك حتى تفجر لنا من الارض ينبوعه
[Silence]
‏and
andyight
لك نخيل
وعنب فتفجر الانهار خلالها تفجيes
[Silence]
of palms and not only that we want
rivers to flow here and there. ‏one
right here
and not
السماء كما زعمت علينا كسفا
[Silence]
او تاتي بالله الملائكه قبيله
او يكون لك بيت من زخرف
‏want
you
want to gather us and we want to watch
you into the heavens in front of us as
we watching.
‏not believe you even if you do that
until we see you come back down with a
book written from Allah and give it to
us then we believe in you
this is what they mean when they say
why doesn't he provide us with a miracle
these are the miracles they speaking
about it's clear that these are
absurdities this is nonens
these are the rings of
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قل سبحان ربي هل كنت الا بشرا رسولا
‏Glory to my but a messenger a human
being you bearing aage
in otheres
he is comm الله
عند الله
say to them
miracles are to the of they are not to
me i don't make
‏are by
the
you are not
are
a messenger
and so
is the one who makes these miracles it
is through the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
aller
mir
bestow
سبحانه وتعالى
اولم يكفهم انا انزلنا عليك الكتاب يتلى
عليهم
سبحانه وتعالى
‏Bit
mirl
من الانبياء من قبلي الا اوتي من الايات
ما مثله امن عليه البشر
وانما كان الذي اوتيته وحيا اوحاه الله
الي فارجو ان اكون اكثرهم تابعا يوم
القيامه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
was mir
‏that so compelling and above susp and
rejection that could not find a way to
refute them and it would comp people
into belief because of what they and i
have been given the words of i have been
given theران aevelation
from
i have been given aevelation
the greatest
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لولاكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين انك
حميد مجيد
اللهم ربنا اننا نسالك باسمائك الحسنى
وصفاتك العلى ان تغفر لنا خطايانا اللهم
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابراء مع الابرار ربنا واتنا
ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد ربنا اننا نشهدك
ونشهد ملائكتك
وجميع خلقك باننا نشهد انك انت الله لا
اله الا انت ونشهد ان محمدا عبدك ورسولك
امنا به امنا به فاغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو
عبيدك بنو امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا
حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك
سميت به نفسك او انزلته في كتابك او علمته
احدا من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب
عندك ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم
علمنا منه ما جاهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان
تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا يا ربنا
يا حيي يا كريم يا من يستحيي من عبده اذا
ما رفع اليك
يديه ان تردهما خائبتين صفرا ها نحن نتبتل
اليك ونتوكل عليك اللهم ربنا اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اجمعين ربنا لا تؤاخذنا بما فعل
السفهاء منا ربنا ربنا اقسم لنا من خشيتك
ما تحول به بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك
ما تبلغ نا به جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به
علينا مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا
واجعل فارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك
والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المضطه واخواتنا في
غزه وفلسطين وفي كل مكان اللهم انصرهم على
من عداهم اللهم انصرهم على من عاداهم
اللهم انصرهم نصرا مؤز زرى اللهم اجعلهم
على عدوهم ظاهرين قاهرين
منصورين
راغمين لعدوك وعدوهم يا رب العالمين اللهم
عليك باعدائهم واعدائك اعداء الدين اللهم
عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين اللهم
زلزل اركانه
صدع بنيانه اللهم اقتل اجناده اللهم اللهم
اجعل قتلاهم في النيران واجعل احيائهم في
ذل وهوان واقذف الرعب في قلوبهم وردهم
خائبين و وردهم مكبوتين يا رب العالمين
اللهم اجعل شهدائنا وقتلانا في الجنان وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا اعتدلوا ست شولدر تو شولدر
‏main
وصل الله ومن قطع صفا قطعه الله
make
الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل يا
ايها الكافرون
لا
اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد ولا
انا عابد ما عبدتم
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم
وليدين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اذا جاء
نصر الله والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره
انه
كان توابا
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبرطيبات
والسلام
[Silence]
بسم ‏.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم وعليكم
‏That's right here.
Oh, you have
come over here.
Just come over here. It's right here.
‏hereلاشقامه
[Silence]
صلاه الفجر ان شاء الله
5 صلاه العشاء
صلاه الفجر
صلاه العشاء
8 جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
‏Where's your dad? Oh, there he